- How's it going?
- Going good.
- It's decent.
- Is that it?
- So, I grew up in Russia.
I lived there from ages three to 15.
Ever since we moved to the US,
I've always been confused
by this question,
how's it going?
Like, no one ever answers the question.
All right, I'm going to prove it to you.
How's it going?
Nothing.
- What's up?
- Not even a little detail.
How's it going?
Again, nothing.
I got this.
What does that mean?
How's it going?
- How's it going?
- He answered my, how's it
going, with a how's it going.
So now that I've proved to you that
nobody ever answers the question,
how's it going, I'm going
to actually take some time
to sit down next to someone and
see if we can have a genuine conversation.
- How's it going, man?
- How you doing?
- Good, dude. Busy.
Yeah, it's been cra, I
mean, it's been crazy.
- How's it going?
Good?
- Yeah, good thanks.
- Cool.
- Aw, this is my--
- Nice to meet you.
- Hi.
How's it going?
- Hey.
- How's your day?
- Nice to meet you.
- Good?
- Good.
- Yeah, I give up.
That was the most awkward
thing I've ever experienced.
I thought it was going to be a video
where I like, met all these people.
No, it's extremely uncomfortable.
It's awkward.
No one wants to talk about their day
or like, open up their feelings.
So instead of putting myself through more
awkward interactions,
I'm going to go around
with a microphone.
I'm going to see why people think no one
answers the question, how's it going.
(cheerful electronic music)
- Sarah, do you have
time for an interview?
- I--
- Too late, we're gonna do it, so.
- It's a one question interview.
How's it going?
- It's going good.
- Eh, it's all right.
How's it going with you?
- It's good.
- Good.
- So how many times have you heard
how's it going in the past week?
- Everyday.
How many times have you answered it
other than saying it's fine?
- Never. (laughing)
- Why do you think no one ever answers
the question, how's it going?
- I just had this problem.
I was in LA and everybody
was answering me.
- You don't want to get
too personal I guess.
- I think it's because usually
the answer is too depressing.
I mean, go to a therapist.
- Nobody's ever going
to say it's going bad.
- I once tried changing how
are you to are you good?
And everyone was like, do I look okay?
Is there something wrong?
- I hate when people,
like if people were to
really ask me that because it would like,
uncork some deep shit.
- I never ask.
- Oh, you never ask?
- I just give like the head
nod and if you give it back,
then I know you're good.
- I honestly think the
world would be better
if we just didn't talk to people at all.
- What I'm realizing is that everyone
at Buzzfeed hates interaction
and is bitter and I'm
the only one who cares
about connecting with other human beings.
- I guess I could get rid of
how's it going completely.
- My problem with how's it going
is when people ask and
immediately stop listening.
- So how was your day?
- It's good.
- Ding!
(laughing)
- So I'm currently editing this video
and I just watched back all the footage.
Even though this video is silly and funny
and it's not supposed to be serious,
I feel like there's actually a pretty
important lesson to be
learned from this video.
I think there's something
so important about
listening and talking
to the people around you
because you never know
who needs to be talked to
or who wants to be heard
or who has some problems
that they need to share,
so it's really important
to listen and you should take the time to
sit down and talk to the
people you care about
and really ask people how's it going.
So if you guys feel like it,
in the comments below, just
tell me how it's going.